Tom Emer with us right now the House
Majority Whip so if anyone is going to
move the ball or at least get a sense of
where that ball is it would be hey uh
Congressman great to have you good to be
with you Neil is there going to be a
deal first off well it's a great
question uh you heard Chad perriam say
that uh three weeks now we've been
hearing there's going to be some kind of
agreement we still have not seen
legislative text well you heard some of
the rumored elements like U you know
president of soon as he signs off on it
he's going to shut the border down he's
going to limit it to 5,000 a day you've
heard that what do you think of that the
proof will be in the text I've heard it
but you've got an Administration now
that uh since they took office more than
three years ago they have completely
opened the southern border uh through
some 64 executive actions they
effectively undid all of the work that
had been done by the previous
administration to seal the Border uh
you've got a record number 300,000 over
300 ,000 came across the border in
December Neil think about this for a
second they waited almost a month to
release that number and they they dumped
it on a Friday night at the same time
they're putting out what I would suggest
is a very disingenuous statement from
the White House about things that nobody
has actually had uh the opportunity to
study and verify um a lot has been said
that Donald Trump doesn't want a border
deal because it's a great election issue
uh and he's more or less sent the word
out to you and your colleagues don't
don't give an inch on this is that true
uh no that is a uh I would say that that
is a narrative that's been created by
people who uh want to give cover to the
administration uh the uh former
president president Trump uh what he's
saying is the same thing that Mike
Johnson and House Republicans are saying
let's make sure that what we do secures
the southern border I mean you could do
things like uh uh restore the remaining
Mexico policy that the the Trump
administration had in place right Neil
that would staunch 70% of the flow
across our Southern border overnight and
this is a much bigger deal you could
just Deport more people right we we
Deport a fraction of the people we're
running at about one5 the level we used
to right kind of hard to do that when uh
this Administration doesn't even know
where they are because of Catch and
Release which should also be uh uh
removed they don't know they've released
40% of those that have come across the
border you're talking about 8 .3 million
since these guys took over the Biden
Administration plus another 1.7 known
Goda aways those are the ones we know
about but would it would some I get
everything you're saying sir but would
some deal be better than no deal the
Wall Street Journal looked into this and
said giving up on a border security bill
could be a self-inflicted GOP wound
President Biden would claim that
Republicans want border chaos as an
election issue rather than solving the
problems voter anger May over time move
Mr Biden to the GOP and the public will
have a point cynicism rules what do you
think the only reason that President
Biden is even interested in discussion
discussing this issue Neil is because it
has now become a political liability for
the White House and he's nervous why not
take his bait and say all right we're
going to hold you to this that is
essentially what the House Republicans
have done yeah show us the text let's
make sure that what we do on the
southern border is a substantive fix not
just words so substantive to you would
not be allowing uh in other words
getting a shutdown going only when it
hits 5,000 because that's still a a lot
of people who get in Jay Johnson who is
the uh ran the Department of Homeland
Security under Obama once said a
thousand coming across our Southern
border is a crisis Neil how can you
suddenly acknowledge and why would any
member of Congress Republican or
Democrat suggest now that it's okay to
have 5,000 or less coming across your
Southern border so as it stands now with
even the rumored numbers you've heard
congressman and I I I guess you are on
the same page as Speaker Johnson this is
unacceptable as it stands with what
you've heard well I have a different job
than the speaker and what I would tell
you is if you're giving the president uh
additional uh Parole Authority to admit
up to 50,000 more people a year if
you're doing the 5,000 Plus One On the
Border over a certain period of time and
giving them discretion if you're not
ending Catch and Release if you're not
uh uh restoring remain in Mexico I'm
going to have a very difficult time
getting the votes that are necessary
even if it comes to the floor isn't this
Congress something that even Donald
Trump wanted some of the other issues
that might be addressed you're quite
right we don't know we don't know this
Asylum issue for one thing he had said
back in 2018 that the biggest loophole
drawing a legal aliens to our borders is
the use of fraudulent or meritless
Asylum claims he said it's really up to
Congress to overcome open borders
obstruction this might and to your point
might be a start in that direction go
ahead take the president's bait this
would be a victory for Donald Trump
coming in if he does get elected
president and he could say that they did
what I told them they should have done
years ago remember Neil uh we haven't
talked about it yet this morning but
House Republicans last May passed the
strongest border security bill that has
been passed in 20 years which included
fixes to theing democratic vote yeah but
never get to the Senate right uh well
again now you see the problem if you are
serious about securing the Border then
you have to look at the uh the bill that
the Republicans passed out of the house
I would argue that you don't have to
have everything in it because you don't
have control of all of government we are
one half of one third of the system but
you do have to have substantive things
that people can look at and say that is
actually solving the problem um do you
think Donald
Trump and his solution and now you you
said that he has not been pressuring
lawmakers to to to pass on this others
say he is but that this is Donald
Trump's agenda here I think the same
agenda that we all have Donald Trump
secured the Border when he was in the
White House Neil this Administration has
undone all of the great work with
executive orders so your point was I
think you were telling me during the
break President Biden could undo that
with executive orders of his own to undo
the executive orders he signed right
because that's what opened up the border
and I think when you talk about
president Trump he's talking about what
all the rest of us are you are not a
country unless you have a border and a
border that you enforce uh we need to
have we need to restore not only what uh
president Trump did but then we need to
pass legislation so we eliminate uh all
of this flexibility that allows someone
to go into office and undo all the
protections that have been created real
quickly sir while I have you the
president said he wasn't really fond of
this RNC effort to essentially
coordinate him the party nominee or the
presumptive nominee uh recognizing I
guess we're to contest into this Iowa
New Hampshire it looks like a
prohibitive lead he has going in South
Carolina do you believe after South
Carolina if Nikki Haley is blown out
that she should bow out uh Donald Trump
is going to be our nominee that that is
what I know so it's up to Nikki and
everybody else how they want does she
harm the party's tting and some of your
colleagues say she does absolutely not
there's a great discussion but that's up
to Nikki she has to make that evaluation
herself Donald Trump will be the
candidate and by the way I really
appreciate what he said yesterday or
what the day before when he said no
don't be doing this uh you know the
presumptive nominee what about his going
after those who give her money that
they're on a black list all I can do is
focus on the next election and we're
going to keep uh focused on the border
keep the government running and try to
take care of our allies around the world
well understood on all fronts very good
Senor Congressman thank you for coming
in the flesh I didn't know I'd see you
in the flesh I'm Steve D I'm Brian kilme
and I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis